[Music]
across the country
help is wanted and businesses can't fill
positions fast enough
i'm in a war for talent if you do not
jump to make an offer to an applicant
at the end of the interview they are
lost and increasingly
it takes more than an offer wawa is
growing many jobs now come with
incentives like sign on bonuses
500 new hire bonus and freebies have
been offered for just showing up to an
interview
but with more than 9 million people
still out of work and a record number of
jobs available
why are these additional offers needed
and are they working
what we're seeing in this unusual labor
market is a resurgence
in leverage for lower wage workers and
we really haven't seen that
in this country for at least 50 years
before the pandemic the labor market was
tight with a jobless rate near a 50-year
low
then millions lost their jobs hourly
restaurant
retail and hotel workers were hit
particularly hard
now as quickly as the economy has
reopened those employers are trying to
staff back up
but many workers remain on the sideline
for a variety of reasons
including coveted concerns child care
and extended unemployment benefits
employers right now are frantically
trying to make sure that they can take
advantage
of the opening up of the economy and
salvage what has been an impossible last
14 15 months for them by ramping up
their businesses very quickly
but it's hard to do that if you don't
have all your workers
in place that's something omni hotels
and resorts knows well
in february i had 200 jobs open
today i have 2 800 jobs open
and i've hired 5000 since february
so we are having explosive
demand to get those roles filled the
company like many others
has turned to incentives including free
housing for summer workers in certain
markets a 250
signing bonus three free nights at an
omni hotel and a set of knives for new
culinary hires
workers who stay past labor day get
another 500
and entrance into omni's management
development program we're used to
interviewing people and having several
applicants for a role and
taking our time and having them come
back for a second interview
you can't do that anymore for it's hard
to fill culinary roles omni recently
decided
we'll add two trainers to help give
inexperienced applicants
on the job training i think a lot of
companies would say oh
you've never cooked you've never been in
a kitchen we don't need you and i'm like
look
five people that want to work for us
bring them in we'll find a way to make
it work
omni's incentives come on top of wage
increases
the company says hourly wages were up as
much as 20 from a year ago in some
markets
that bump isn't just to compete with
other hotels both target and walmart
have agreed to raise wages this year
and amazon is offering a thousand dollar
signing bonus in some locations
they're going after the same labor i'm
going after
and i think that was a big wake-up call
for the hotel industry
labor department data show average
weekly wages in leisure and hospitality
have increased 10.7 percent since the
start of the pandemic
outpacing the private sector overall and
that's not always the case right a lot
of times it's
higher tax higher educated workers that
see the bigger pay increases
right now we're seeing the reverse and
that's why you have all this activity
around bonuses
but are wage increases and job
incentives actually drawing workers back
into the workforce
it's a mixed bag omni has hired about 3
000 people since it began offering
incentives labor department data show
that the sector overall
added the most jobs in june suggesting
the incentives
may be helping we still have a lot of
job openings millions of job openings in
these
these sectors so it suggests that either
some employers are going to need to have
to do even more
or they're going to have to wait it out
and see if the labor market finds its
level in the fall
one reason the fall is important that's
when the federal government's expanded
unemployment benefits are said to expire
nationwide
though more than 20 states have already
stopped paying the extra 300
a week payments some economists point to
that benefit
as one reason why workers aren't rushing
to fill open jobs
many people on unemployment benefits are
earning you know the equivalent of
working full-time for 15 an hour so if
you're offering less than that or about
that it's pretty hard to attract workers
a recent study from jefferies found that
people are leaving state unemployment
roles more quickly in the states that
have already cut off the federal
expanded benefits
suggesting more are re-entering the
workforce but some economists say
the benefits are giving people time to
find the right job
and maybe even hold out for a better
offer when you look at the data
the states that have had the biggest
decreases in
unemployment are also states that have
very generous unemployment benefits so
there's not a direct correlation that
higher unemployment benefits are meaning
people aren't getting back to work
so today i'm pleased to announce an
incentive program that i feel is a
positive step
towards getting some people off
unemployment and back
into the workforce recently states have
started offering their own cash
incentives to residents rejoining the
workforce
colorado's program which had more than
eighteen thousand applicants paid up to
sixteen hundred dollars to people
returning to work full-time
still for many it's not about the money
concerns about the pandemic remain
specifically in face to face work and
child care is keeping millions of
parents
particularly women at home and frankly i
think people are kind of weary
this has been a really hard period of
time
that we've gone through and and you know
people are
sort of taking a moment to think about
what are my priorities
whatever the reason it's likely we'll
continue to see signing bonuses and
other incentives for as long as
businesses compete to fill these jobs
the increased wages economists say will
stick around even longer
if things are working we're going to
keep doing them but if they're not
solving our problem
we're going to have to come up with new
ways to to
skin this cat because we cannot
just post the jobs and assume people are
going to show up